alors raphaël liogier professeur des
universités en sociologie et en
philosophie à sciences po aix en
provence et chercheur au sophiapol à
paris 10 nanterre
[Musique]
ça s'est traduit par effectivement le
fait auditionner des élus des élus qui
peuvent être des parlementaires soit
sénateurs soit député soi-même soi-même
parlementaires européens ou des élus
plus locaux des élus de communes plus ou
moins grant a peut être des petites
communes et de les laisser parler de
leurs expériences en terme de solidarité
de sociétés de leur expérience ou six
ans dans le cadre des innovations qu'ils
peuvent avoir eu qui peuvent avoir mis
eux-mêmes en place et qui peuvent servir
à la réfection de façon très concrète et
d'essayer d'avoir une perspective
globale sur ses expériences
particulières donc de lier le concret
vraiment dans ce qu'ils doivent plus
concret avec la remontée du terrain avec
des objectifs qui sont des objectifs
plus généraux plus théorique de ceux de
solidarité ensuite il ya un deuxième
groupe d'individus s'est dit ce qu on
dit ce qu'on appelle prosaïquement la
société civile en particulier
représentés par des chercheurs des
universitaires des gens d'expérience sur
le sujet et il excédé de faire partager
avec l'expérience des élus ou des
militants même pour partager une explosé
ces deux types de personnes et enfin
troisièmement c'est effectivement le
sondage d'études de remonter ddd des
militants qui nous a permis non pas dès
le début parce qu'on n'a pas eue dès le
début mais qui nous a permis par la
suite progressivement de réajuster de
deux pauses et peut-être des meilleures
questions est d'arriver à faire ce qu'on
appelait jadis des synthèses les partis
politiques
toute société fonctionne avec la
solidarité c'est à dire qu'il faut
constituer un organisme solidaire qu'il
faut qu'ils aient des liens
il faut qu'ils aient de
l'interdépendance le synonyme ce serait
interdépendance
les points seuil ans était cette
question de l'humanisme la question de
l'humanisme c'est pas une question
abstraite c'est comment continuer à être
humain dans un monde littéralement
submergé par la technoscience par une
technologie qui sous certains aspects
peut sembler mécanisée nous réduire puis
il ya une autre question c'est la
question de la responsabilité
une question centrale la question de la
responsabilité qui peut se traduire
comme une responsabilité entre les
générations la responsabilité des plus
vieux des plus jeunes et des plus jeunes
vis-à-vis des plus vieux la
responsabilité à l'intérieur même de la
famille la responsabilité des natifs
vis-à-vis de ceux qui sont immigrés qui
n'ont pas eu peut-être la citoyenneté
française de façon naturelle comme nous
nous l'avons eue ou comme la plupart des
gens la majorité des français leur lutte
à dire tout ça c'est relève de la
responsabilité puis la responsabilité
même si on n'en a pas eu le temps d'en
parler beaucoup dans l'atelier en lui
même
ça a été quand même évoqué la
responsabilité du point de vue éthique
c'est bien du point de vue de la
bioéthique et des de l'évolution des
technosciences eu des pratiques
[Musique]
les centristes sont conscients de
l'existence des différences et même y
sont ils valorisent les différents les
différences mais avec justement cette
idée de solidarité entre ces différences
d'empathie et finalement le fam ans de
l'histoire aujourd'hui qui représente en
même temps en sens inverse le principal
risque de nos sociétés c'est l'autonomie
parce que le risque essentiel nos
sociétés c'est la perte d'autonomie
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
en cette heure matinale de dimanche
matin j'espère que vous allez bien
très heureuse de vous retrouver pour
cette matinale consacrée aux liens qui
nous unissent
après des tables rondes très
passionnante il aime et des forums avec
une parlementaire on a parlé de
reconquête de territoires de droit de
démocratie on va évoquer ensemble des
enjeux sociaux qui sont devant nous qui
attendent nos concitoyens à court à
moyen et à long terme
on a vécu pendant des mois séparés les
uns des autres une séparation forcée
ça a mis en lumière notre impérieux
besoin d'avoir des liens les uns avec
les autres
je vais m'en référer à emmanuelle millet
qui est un philosophe personnages qu'on
aime bien dans cette maison disait qui
dit je n'existe que dans la mesure où
j'existe pour autrui
il ajoute à la limite être c'est aimer
le paradoxe convient dans nos sociétés
individualistes qu'on a vécu pendant
cette crise de ce besoin des autres ça
souligne ne fait qu' on n'est pas
seulement des individus mais aussi des
êtres de relations et ses biens qui nous
unissent et qui nous permettent de faire
communauté
on en est aussi convaincu au modem c'est
des biens entre les peuples en
particulier entre les peuples européens
donc au cours de cette table ronde on
abordera un certain nombre de sujets
avec les invités que je vais présenter
juste après on va aborder les questions
solidarité entre générations de jeunesse
de vieillesse de culture on va également
avoir un goût perspective européenne
cette perspective européenne qui vous
l'avez constaté à manier tous nos
échanges depuis hier et on s'en réjouit
alors pour évoquer tous ces enjeux on a
le plaisir d'accueillir cinq invités
alors pas formidable j'attendais le
cinquième il est arrivée bienvenue jean
marie donc on a le plaisir d'accueillir
me cinq invités que je vais présenter
rapidement
jean jacques aillagon qui est ancien
ministre de la culture membre du bureau
exécutif du mouvement démocrate
bienvenue jean jacques
et merci de ta présence laurence parent
qui député européen et membre de la
commission culture éducation bienvenue
et laurence et merci de ta présente jean
jacques jégou 22e jean jacques qui est
trésorier du mouvement démocrate
président guy fed membre du bureau
exécutif du modem l'avenue jean jacques
qui amena biche qui est deuxième
adjointe au maire de saint-etienne en
charge de la politique de la ville de
l'éducation populaire de la laïcité des
relations avec les cultes
elle est aussi vice-présidente de
saint-etienne métropole il ya des
présidents du modem de la loire vient
aussi fiable et merci de ta présence que
6 et jean marie vanlerenberghe qui est
donc sénateur du pas de calais
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales au sénat
une vice-présidente du modem bienvenue
jean marais merci de ta fréquence aussi
voilà maintenant que les présentations
sont faites je voulais adresser ma
première question à jean marie
vanlerenberghe
mais je précise bien sûr que chervin
taraude vous pouvez poser vos questions
et nous assurons relayer et je rentrais
le relais en traits de nos invités donc
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions nous
les attendons donc ma première question
à jean ballongue berenberg
en commençant avec un sujet qui a fait
l'actualité au cours de cette crise
le grand âge jean m'arrive d'en conclure
qu'ils aient tué sénateur du pas de
calais tué également rapporteur général
de la commission des affaires sociales
au sénat
tu est également vice président de la
mission d'évaluation et de contrôle de
la sécurité sociale tu as également été
membre de l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des politiques de santé
ancien maire d'arras et donc tu as
beaucoup réfléchi non seulement à la
théorisation et la réflexion autour des
politiques publiques mais aussi leur
mise en pratique sur sur un territoire
donc jean marie on a bien vu que la
crise du coc vide avait jeté une lumière
crue sur la solitude des personnes âgées
avec les enjeux aux visites familiales
et donc maintien à domicile
on a tous vécu ces difficultés à être
éloignés de nos grands parents de nos
proches et la difficulté aussi pour eux
d'être éloigné de nous donc le modem
avait activement participé en juin
dernier à la création d'une cinquième
branche autonomie à la sécurité sociale
qui était justement dédiée à la prise en
charge des personnes en situation de
dépendance et on le sait ses dépenses
liées à la dépendance vont
considérablement augmenter dans les
prochaines semaines et on en parlait en
préparant cette table ronde il ya il
reste du chemin à parcourir
donc la question que je voulais te poser
c'est comment financer cette solidarité
intergénérationnelle cette solidarité
qu'on le doit à nos aînés
quelles pistes sont à l'étude avec les
partenaires sociaux est peut-être plus
généralement est ce que tu peux nous
éclairer voilà sur les enjeux de la
création de cette 5ème branche à toi
jean marie alors jean marc images en
temps
j'espère que tout le monde tente en
gênant quand même comment il entend pas
je tente en parler l'entente bon bah
écoute excuse moi c'était pourtant
branché mm bord je voulais te remercie
effectivement de lancer cette question
sur en saluant l'initiative à la fois
gouvernementales et parlementaires moi
je souligne effectivement que les
parlementaires c'est eux qui ont pris la
décision de créer la cinquième branche à
l'assemblée nationale puis ensuite au
sénat nous l'avons effectivement soutenu
ce qui avait été décidé par le
gouvernement
c'est être fléché effectivement dans les
budgets de la sécurité sociale le
cinquième risque
mais là la décision qui est fondamental
c'est la création d'une branche une
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
concernant effectivement l'autonomie des
personnes âgées mais aussi du handicap
donc je crois que c'est le premier point
depuis une vingtaine d'années tous les
gouvernements ont dit qu'il était
nécessaire de créer cette cinquième
manche mais ne l'ont jamais fait pour
des raisons évidemment financière pour
l'essentiel comment financer cette
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
actuellement dans la série dans les
budgets de l'assurance maladie dans le
budget je dirais de la sécurité sociale
on a fléchi 27 milliards c'est un
dispensés c'était nécessaire bien sûr
mais insuffisant donc intervient en
parallèle
en complément la cns à la caisse
nationale de solidarité d'autonomie et
je dirais que ces différents aspects qui
ont été qui sont effectivement et
importants doivent être aujourd'hui
regardés à la lueur du rapport de
monsieur li bo qui prévoit kif
faudra augmenter les bulles le budget
qui émet de 27 mai beaucoup plus
important avec les fonds complémentaires
des différentes branches autres branches
de la sécurité sociale
ils sont évalués à 60 milliards donc il
va falloir effectivement apporter un
complément qui est aujourd'hui l'enjeu
l'enjeu c'est environ 2 6 à 8 milliards
d'ici 2030
voilà je reviendrai sur ces questions si
vous me permettez un peu plus tard parce
que là je dois mathéron pour une raison
plutôt matériel et personnel
merci et bientôt maman compter le début
de l'annoncé en te remercie beaucoup
et effectivement c'était c'est un
chantier passionnant compliqué et en
même temps fondamentale et donc
effectivement on y reviendra et
j'imagine le grand âge bien sûr est un
chantier fondamental et donc on y
reviendra au cours de nos débats alors
je vais me tourner maintenant vers jean
jacques jégou on a commencé à évoquer le
grand âge et on a évoqué la question de
cette 5ème branche mais bien qui nous
unit c'est aussi une affaire de
redistribution de richesses et vous n'en
parlez en préparant cette offre
cette table ronde les politiques
soutiennent elles sont efficaces quand
elles réduisent les inégalités
aujourd'hui en selon les derniers
chiffres de l'insee le taux de pauvreté
en france est de 14% est en augmentation
et il concerne à près de 10 millions de
personnes en france
aujourd'hui la pauvreté concerne un
joueur qui près de 10 millions de
personnes et bien sûr ou au modem on est
très sensible à ces questions et pour
autant on voit que malgré tout ce qu'on
peut chercher à mettre en oeuvre
on a dû des difficultés à réduire cette
pauvreté
je vais m'appuyer sur bertrand badré
l'ancien numéro deux de la banque
mondiale qui était intervenu lors du
grand départ modem qui a vient de sortir
un ouvrage
non sérieusement changer le monde dans
lequel il met en garde le président ma
crainte justement contre l'explosion des
inégalités et le déclin des classes
moyennes est je le rappelle avant
d'arriver à ma question
aujourd'hui en france il faut avoir en
tête que traits d'un bon cran sur cinq
vit en situation de pauvreté en
particulier dans les familles
monoparentales et donc jean-jacques la
question que je voulais te poser comment
expliquer qu'un pays qui redistribue aux
temps des richesses ne parviennent pas à
faire diminuer la pose de ces gens là
qui tu peux lui apporter un éclairage
sur ce sujet oui oui bonjour à tous et
pas si vous m'entendez parce que moi je
n'ai pas entendu le moindre jour 2 de
mon ami jean marie vanlerenberghe
j'espère que je suis audible pour chacun
d'entre vous la grille en cause ali
c'est quand même je n'ai pas la
prétention d'apporter en quelques
minutes une réponse mais c'est un fait
je crois que elle donnait les chiffres
à tout à l'heure sur les 14 % de pauvres
dans ce pays ce qui est absolument
intolérable
mais je crois aussi qu'il faut dire que
nous sommes le pays qui auront
distribuons le plus de richesses c'est à
dire 60 % des richesses produites par le
pays sont redistribuées alors la
question qui peut se poser c'est
pourquoi une telle inefficacité
finalement parce que ceux-ci brasse un
certain nombre de deux dizaines voire de
centaines guillard et on peut se poser
la question que alors que notre notre
système notre système social qui est de
solidarité qui a été organisé déjà
maintenant il ya un certain nombre
d'années puisqu'il s'agit des programmes
du conseil national de la résistance qui
a été en 45 mises en place et sur lequel
nous sommes toujours et j
on n'en parle pas souvent on a souvent
rajouter un certain nombre de mille
feuilles comme on dit en matière de
droit davantage
on a réduit on a réduit le départ à la
retraite d'un système de retraite qui
est certainement l'un des plus généreux
au monde
on a un système de santé qui est encore
l'un des plus efficaces même si à
l'occasion de la pandémie que nous
connaissons nous avons connu dans la
première vague et que nous semblons
devoir encore connaître dans les
prochaines semaines il ya des
insuffisances mais il reste l'un des
meilleurs au monde
alors je crois que nous avons une
exigence que nous ne nous n'avons pas
toujours la possibilité de réaliser
parce que nous sommes dans un pays qui
connaît beaucoup de défections
quelquefois certains pourraient dire
beaucoup trop s'est il n'y a pas une
année où pratiquement ces deux sont très
rares où on renouvelle pas tel ou tel
que ce soit bien sûr l'élection
présidentielle maintenant tous les cinq
ans ou législative qui sont attachées ou
les élections locales
il ya donc certainement de ce fait une
appétence à pratiquer des réformes voire
même à essayer de de valider
l'efficacité des sommes les sommes
dépensées
je crois que je me doute connaissant
bien jean marie et sa compétence en la
matière parce que rapporteur général du
plfss c'est un poste extrêmement
important et elle a une vision globale
des choses j'ai moi même été pendant
quelques années
rapporteur du budget de la santé au
sénat aussi et rapporteur pour avis du
du psss on voit bien tout de même chaque
fois que l'on veut mettre en place de
nouvelles dispositions la quantité
d'argent qu'il faut et en plus l'argent
est rare maintenant et
vous parlais tout à l'heure de la
cinquième branche la cinquième branche
est indispensable mais aujourd'hui on a
encore des pistes qui ne sont pas bien
défini pour savoir si on va travailler
un jour de plus un jour férié de plus
par exemple s'il va falloir augmenter
les retraites
les sièges et pour les pour les
retraités voir augmenter globalement la
csg toutes ces questions bien sûr sont
éminemment politique même si le principe
comme tu le rappeler alice de la
solidarité delà de l'histoire de notre
pays
l'humanisme des de lien qu'il ya entre
les générations on s'aperçoit que
aujourd'hui c'est de plus en plus
difficile de maintenir des équilibres ou
même des capacités de financement et il
va falloir en tout cas que l'on puisse
expertise est beaucoup mieux
l'efficacité des actions qui sont menées
c'était une de nos faiblesses je crois
dans ce pays où quelquefois il y a aussi
des je ne dirais pas des solidarités
excessive m'étonnerait qu'un seul
exemple puisque j'ai été maire pendant
près de trente et un ans je vois bien
aujourd'hui la démagogie les élus
quelquefois qui n'osent pas dire quel
est le coût réel par exemple de la
petite enfance avec les crèches et
centres de loisirs la restauration
scolaire
tout ceci coûte énormément d'argent et
tout le monde pense que c'est normal et
c'est une solidarité évidence en en
planète réellement le coup d'ailleurs
quelques fois des villes ont du mal à
l'estivé elle même donc médaillables
activité au moins de donner des
priorités on parlait bien sûr de la
dépendance qu'il ya un vrai problème
mais il y à d'autres problèmes qu'il
faut qu'on évalue et qu'on soit en
capacité de continuer à financer
faute de quoi notre société ne pourra
pas continuer à être l'image du thème
qui nous réunit ce matin sur les liens
qui nous unissent et dany remercie
beaucoup jean-jacques je rebondis sur ce
que tu dis en effet tututu évoqué la
question de la dea
ago j en disant cela n'explique pas
suffisamment à nos concitoyens le cours
des choses et c'est vrai tant qu'élu
local je vois bien que quand on paie de
tels tarifs à la crèche en réalité pour
la collectivité c'est beaucoup plus
or les concitoyens ne le savent pas
toujours et j'allais reprendre le terme
de démagogie puisque nos oppositions et
je crois toujours par les merengue ont
tenu justement sur cette question de la
création de la cinquième manche
nos positions nous faisons aucune taxé
de démagogie justement en disant en
substance vous êtes bien gentils de
créer cette cette branche
mais n'est ce pas un risque justement à
anost être incapable de financer donc
est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu
démagogique
peut-être alors on voit que jean marie
vanlerenberghe hébreu venu peut
peut-être avant de passer effectivement
là à d'autres d'autres sujets de débats
sur le grand âge je me fais lui le
l'écho de questions de nos internautes
nous avons pierre qui nous demandent
justement sur le grand âge face au
vieillissement de la population
ne faut-il pas un autre modèle que les
ehpad pour permettre à nos anciens de
vivo chez eux dans des lieux partagé
avec d'autres générations
qu'est-il prévu pour les aidants
familiaux et aussi pour tout ce qui
permet le maintien à domicile ça c'est
judith peut-être jean-jacques jean-marie
et ensuite je passerai la parole à
d'autres
si tu peux nous éclairer sur justement
au delà de cette 5ème branche
comment on se projette pour mieux
accompagner nos aînés dans l'est dans
les années qui viennent
oui on va
pense que c'est le véritable enjeu au
delà des aspects financiers vous
m'excuserez tout à l'heure d'avoir
interrompu mon explication pourra y
revenir plus complètement plus tard
c'est pas à mon sens à mon sens est
essentielle l'essentiel c'est qu'est ce
qu'on va en faire et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la demande majoritaire
des personnes âgées c'est de rester à
domicile et malheureusement aujourd'hui
les conditions pour le maintien à
domicile sont ne sont pas tout à fait
réunies elles sont insuffisantes ont
tous les cas il ya effectivement et
j'utilise personnellement
chez moi les soins effectivement pour
des soins à mon épouse une association
je vois bien effectivement le dévouement
extrême de ces personnes qui travaillent
à domicile mais aussi la suffisance de
ses moyens et surtout l'amour je dirais
la non reconnaissance
elles sont très mal payés ce sont pour
l'essentiel à 98 % des femmes et elles
sont très mal payés
d'ailleurs on a vu d'ailleurs avec le co
vide qu'on avait oublié complètement
j'ai dû intervenir ix et x fois pour que
le ministre le premier ministre prenne
en compte
effectivement la prime pour les
soignants à domicile donc l'enjeu il est
là alors il va falloir financer l'aide à
domicile qui peut être d'ailleurs moins
coûteuse que l'ehpad et est surtout
beaucoup plus je dirais rassurante
à une condition c'est qu'à qu'on arrive
à vaincre la solitude parce que le
risque il est là c'est vous êtes à
domicile mais si vous l'êtes plus tout à
fait autonome vous êtes cloué dans votre
domicile sans contact avec l'extérieur
donc voilà il faut trouver un substitut
à l'ehpad qui est une sorte de
d'enfermement parfois absolument
nécessaire pour des personnes qui sont
véritablement en manque totale
d'autonomie et qui sont dépendantes sur
le plan médical mais il faut trouver les
solutions pour accompagner à domicile
les personnes âgées
je crois que c'est ça le c'est un
changement paradigme qui doit qui doit
s'opérer et qui doit parfaitement
s'intégrer dans la loi la future loi
autonome merci beaucoup jean marigny
alors effectivement là on a eu
[Musique]
d'échangés sur le grand âge et je note
la remarque d'un de nos internautes de
jean-paul qui nous dit nous n'avons plus
de vue d'ensemble de la société chacun
voit midi à sa porte
effectivement il n'y a peut-être un
enjeu et on l'évoquait aussi de comment
on fait société tous ensemble pour
aborder une autre
un autre volet de la solidarité je vais
me tourner vers laurence parent parce
que laurence qui ne s'occupe qui est
membre donc de la commission éducation
culture au parlement européen au cou a
beaucoup qui ont amené ce que vous
voulez je n'ai le l'actrice couronné
moore après une machine peu vide fermé
pour attendait grande partie couverts
vous n'êtes en formation et leur
empreinte icg parlement européen tu peux
aussi vous aider à prendre un peu de
hauteur et largeur la focale essayer de
comprendre
plus généralement comment est-ce que
l'union européenne elle a réfléchi à
cette question de l'aide à la jeunesse
je vais ce qui a été impactée dans toute
l'europe
ou est ce que c'est la cuite vous vers
thann manière elle peut pas constituer
une opportunité que l'europe fasse
preuve de plus d'audace trop vite à la
jeunesse une chose que tu peux être
d'éclairer lui rentrer sur comment
l'europe essaie de rendre le tout
cohérent entre les différents plans que
cherche à mettre en oeuvre des pays
comment est-ce que vous menez c'est de
maintenir aussi un socle européen
bonjour à toutes et tous et merci
beaucoup à l'iss pour ton travail ardu
et matinale alors c'est vrai que moi je
parle peut-être de l'échelle la plus
éloignée a priori de la dimension de
proximité et solidarité
la dimension européenne et pourtant et
pourtant c'est vrai qu'à l'échelle
européenne
cette crise elle s'est soldée dans notre
ensemble politique par une première
historique qui était la véritable
solidarité entre les états membres
puisque nous avons mutualisé entre 27 et
à un emprunt destiné à faire face à la
crise et au delà de cet emprunt de ces
investissements d'avenir on a mutualisé
un projet donc c'est en soi un acte de
solidarité une première qui n'est nam
n'était même pas arrivé lors de la crise
financière de 2008
est ce qu'on peut noter c'est que cet
élan de solidarité il a un nom il
s'appelle en globish européen
next generation ayew c'est à dire qu'il
est conçu pour une nouvelle génération
d'europe mais surtout pour les jeunes
générations de européenne et d'européens
alors quand tu dis 'comment est-ce que
ça a mûri comment ça fédère commença
cimente les plans nationaux de relance
eh bien je dirais que c'est au travers
des grands objectifs qu'il y a dans ses
plans parce que jusqu'à présent on est
c'est vrai qu'on ait beaucoup c'est ce
que le regret que j'ai en ai beaucoup
ensevelis par des annonces en espèces
sonnantes et trébuchantes et bruyant de
2 milliards de la ses 750 milliards pour
ce plan européen qui va être répartie
sous forme de prêts ou de subventions
dans les différents états membres
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière cette
ces milliards qu'elle est et comment on
donne une âme à ces milliards je dis
souvent alors dans le dense qui a été
dressé ce qui s'est construit
dans l'action du parlement européen
puisque on a été très initiateurs de
cette réflexion validé par les chefs
d'état et mis en musique je dirais par
la commission européenne et bien il ya
de grandes perspectives qui sont en soi
des lignes et je dirais des des guides
pour pour les générations pour les
jeunes aujourd'hui
la première bien sûr c'est la transition
écologique pour répondre à la fois une
nécessité et à ce climat d'inquiétude
qui a chez les jeunes qui est tout à
fait justifié donc cette question de la
transition écologique puisque 30% de ce
plan de relance sera destiné à des
investissements dans les la transition
écologique et la deuxième dimension
c'est la transition numérique
donc là on touche du doigt mais en fait
finalement ce qu'on a vécu tout au long
de ce de ce confinement à la fois la
nécessité de ces technologies numériques
pour nous rapprocher aussi pour créer du
lien par ailleurs des grandes questions
d'inégalité de 10 pires des disparités
et puis ensuite bien sûr la
compétitivité de notre continent face à
la concurrence des gaffes à face à la
concurrence de la chine et toutes ces
choses là
donc d'où il tient là finalement jeunes
pia ce projet d'avenir et ce projet
d'avenir il faut que vous vous lac à
parier donc ça veut dire nouvelles
compétences donc éducation-formation
nouvelle façon de vivre et de travailler
bien sûr et et qui pose aussi les biens
sur les question de comment continue à
créer du lien entre nous donc moi je
oui je t'écoute mais je le disais la
effectivement tout pour ceux qui me
suivent ya un léger décalage dans les
interventions donc ça peut l'expliquer
petit décalage entre où je me disais la
jeunesse elle et elle est à la charnière
2d transition écologique et numérique
est effectivement comme tu disais une
focale qu'elle fasse sienne toutes ces
mesures c'est un peu 7d l'idée c'est de
dire d'abord comme toujours les
transitions elles se feront pas sans
inclure tout le monde est donc cette
dimension sociale elle est tout à fait
clé et je c'est là que j'allais arriver
au plan national le plan national il est
tout à fait il inclut 7 cette chose là
puisqu'on dit on va favoriser et on va
pousser le premier emploi on va pousser
les questions d'apprentissage donc ça
c'est tout à fait clé d'emmener tout le
monde dans cette danse est dansé dans
cette période de crise déjà
d'importantes du soutien mais aussi en
formant et en apportant tout le monde
une solution pour qu'ils aient pas huit
cent mille jeunes qui cette année vont
rester sur le bas côté parce que quel
que soit leur niveau maïs trop ils
seront sans emploi
mais je veux dire aussi qu'il ya une
dimension filet de sécurité qui est très
importante pour embarquer les jeunes
pour embarquer les jeunes puisque
l'europe elle elle mobilise un grand
programme qui est la garantie jeunesse
qui a été encore très abondé
en mai 2000 20 pour faire face à toutes
ces questions qui redistribue et aussi
vers les états membres et puis il ya un
autre projet qui est très important élan
on recule de quelques générations qui
est le grand projet d'une garantie
enfants parce que tu parlais de la
pauvreté à l'échelle de la france mais à
l'échelle de rôle l'europe c'est 25% des
enfants qui sont en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté et qui ont un besoin accru
d'assurance sociale et de d'éducation
voilà c'est ça c'est des points très
importants c'est à la fois cette
projection dans des dents dans un avenir
dans un avenir qui reste à inventer et
des opportunités pour les jeunes ne faut
pas dire que cette crise alliés elle est
sans espoir il ya un après mais cette
dimension des dés de solidarité
permanente parce qu'on a c'est c.de
d'angers 1-2 risque de se perdre et
notre mouvement il a des grandes
responsabilités pour assurer cette
cohésion sociale et pour s'y engager
puis je voulais juste conclure mon
intervention en effet ville de l'europe
donc peut être un peu loin sur la
dimension humaine aussi qui nous est
cher puisque ces nouvelles façons d'être
de vivre d'avoir des nouvelles activités
elles vont nous amener à être sans doute
plus mobile on peut être qu'on aura la
chance de vie davantage aux voeux mais
il y aura toujours la question de la
création de liens et à ce titre je
voulais dire l'importance de l'éducation
des échanges et de la culture
jean-jacques aillagon est avec nous et
je suis sûr qu'il va en parler
énormément mais comment on crée ce qui
nous lie et je vais conclure par ça à
moi ou à l'échelle européenne travaille
sur le programme erasmus plus et on sent
que cette question voilà de partager à
tous les niveaux des expériences il est
important est que ce programme erasmus
plus il a l'ambition dans les sept ans à
venir d'être encore plus ouvert à tous
les jeunes quelles que soient leurs
nouveaux donc pour apporter cette
connaissance du monde s'est échangé et
cette formation et avoir cette cette
égalité face aux nouvelles perspectives
voilà sur ce première partie de ma
réponse merci beaucoup laurence merci
et avant de me tourner effectivement
tutu disait à juste titre tu évoquais
laurence à juste titre comment créer de
king et effectivement on va parler de
deux cultures mais je voulais juste
avant avec jean jacques aillagon bien
sûr mais je voulais juste avons relevé
une intervention d'un internaute raphaël
qui nous dit et je trouvais ça
intéressant par rapport à ce que disait
jean jacques jégou et jean marie
vanlerenberghe juste avant raphaël qui
nous dit bonjour je suis toujours
inquiet en entendant que l'on souhaite
augmenter les budgets pour essayer de
satisfaire les besoins de solidarité par
nature dit-il dans ce domaine les
besoins sont illimitées ne serait-il pas
raisonnable de fixer un socle minimum
financées par la solidarité nationale et
aider à la professionnalisation des
bénévoles
alors là c'est intéressant je trouve pas
ce qu en effet en matière de solidarité
potentiellement c'est sans fin peut-être
jean jacques jégou si tu as une réaction
à salé se passe ensuite la parole à jean
jacques aillagon
jean-jacques il faut mettre ton micro
vous m'entendez monde mais oui oui il va
écouter la question d'internaute au coin
du bon sens mais il ya une existence
déjà et jean-marie le sait parfaitement
ça s'appelle l'ondam c'est un indice qui
est fixé en matière de dépenses sociales
par exemple mais qui augmente
au minimum et qui fixé par le
gouvernement au moment de la loi
budgétaire
mais tout ceci ne tient pas compte car
si on fait varier un tant soit peu la
dépense même de façon minime
on ne sait toujours pas si on peut
équilibrer les dépenses
c'est un peu technique je voudrais pas
ennuyer tout le monde mais en tout cas
la question est pertinente
la réalisation est très difficile parce
que souvent eh bien c'est un peu à
tiroirs ouverts
le déficit de la sécurité sociale qui
est actuellement laisse à jean-marie
pour être fixé huit mois et autour de
130 ou 150 milliards et surtout avec
locaux vides depuis depuis le début de
cette année en tout cas c'est une
question qui reste pendante et qui n'est
pas facilement merci beaucoup
jean-jacques gironde je me tourne
maintenant vers jean jacques aillagon
puisque effectivement les liens qui nous
unissent et aussi une affaire de culture
on habitue des temps disons particulier
en matière d'accès à la culture ces
derniers mois on évoquer cela ensemble
jean-jacques en préparant cette
table-ronde tu disais que de ton point
de vue donc jean-jacques que je
présentais ancien ministre de la culture
est également aujourd'hui municipal de
plougasnou donc solidement ancrée en
bretagne et jean-jacques que tu le
disais paradoxalement on n'a jamais
autant eu accès à des contenus culturels
qu'aujourd'hui ces contenus qui
permettent justement de de nous élever
de renforcer finalement notre notre
sentiment d'appartenance à un pays où le
continent et pour autant il ya un sujet
intéressant que tu mentionnait lorsqu'on
préparer cette table ronde les liens qui
nous unissent ils sont finalement aussi
hâte et virtuels il ya par exemple
pendant la crise
beaucoup de cours à distance de contenu
à distance et ça a souligné l'idée que
les territoires étaient inégalement doté
sa souligne donc l'enjeu de l'accès à la
ouverture des territoires en téléphonie
en internet est ce que tu peux nous et
nous apporter son éclairage et ton
expertise sur ces gens je fous là qu
alice d'abord bonjour bonjour également
à tous nos amis de nos collègues la
culture la culture c'est d'une affaire
de lien par excellence qu'est ce que
c'est que la culture sinon un ensemble
de jeudi des valeurs de pratiques
d'objets des monuments par exemple des
oeuvres dans lesquelles une civilisation
un ensemble humain se reconnaît et un
ensemble donc de 10 des deux valeurs etc
qui sont partagés l'un des problèmes de
la situation actuelle de notre monde
sait que société sont vos plus
fractionnées sont vos goûts pu diviser
sont beaucoup moins homogène qu'en
d'autres temps donc on a parfois
l'impression d'une sorte
d'atterrissement justement de julien du
lien du lien culturel ce la raison pour
laquelle j'ai pensé que les politiques
publiques en faveur de la culture que
soient les politiques de l'état
les politiques des collectivités locales
avaient pour mission essentielle de
faire en sorte que ce qui est
spontanément désiré par certains
deviennent désirable par tous et soient
partagées partagé par tous
car en effet pendant longtemps la
question du partage la culture s'est
posé en des termes dans les termes
classiquement les termes conventionnel
historiquement conventionnel il valait
qui est partout des musées des théâtres
qui est partout des bibliothèques des
conservatoires donc des lieux de la
fabrication et de consommation entre
nîmes et de la culture du partage la
culture le mot et plus et puis adapté
aujourd'hui la téléphonie internet font
qu'il ya d'autres voies d'autres canaux
également de diffusion il partage la
culture on l'a vu pendant la terrible
période du
confinement quand chacun étaient obligés
de rester chez soi en tout cas dans un
cercle géographique extrêmement limités
ou les lieux de culture ont été fermés
pendant cette période la possibilité
d'entendre de la musique de d'accéder à
des idées de voir des oeuvres a été
médiatisée par les nouveaux moyens de la
la communication les moyens
contemporains de la communication d'où
la question du caractère très aigu de la
question de l'égalité verture du
territoire de façon à ce que en matière
par exemple d'enseignement
d'enseignement virtuel il n'est pas la
situation de ceux dans les villes qui
pourront accéder facilement à cette
pratique de l'enseignement et ceux qui
se trouvent dans des conditions
géographiques ou techniques plus plu et
rodez et qu'ils devront pas le vert cela
vaut cook également naturellement la
question finalement du contexte social
dans lequel ces pratiques s'exerce là
aussi il y a des fractures territoriales
il y a également des peintures sociales
certains nient lieux sociaux sont plus
appropriés à ce partage facile la
culture soit la culture dans sa réalité
sensible dans sa réalité physique est
quasiment aller au concert aller au
musée mais également se pose la question
naturellement de l'axé virtuel là aussi
la facture sociale les fractures
sociales font qu'il est plus aisé plus
spontané plus facile de faire dans
certains contextes sociaux que connaît
notre d'où la question naturellement de
l'objectif de démocratisation culturelle
que se sont fixés qu'on se fixe et que
se sont fixés tous les gouvernements
tous les ministres la culture c'est l'un
des grands thèmes
un des politiques culturelles que celui
de la démocratisation culturelle mais
c'est à certaines scènes vraiment
essentiel il se pose aujourd'hui un dans
d'autres termes ou non se posent les
époques de mal
il ya 60 ans ou 50 ans il a 40 ans mais
l'exercice
l'exercice est et est passionnant merci
beaucoup jean-jacques pour fait premiers
éléments de réponse et d'ailleurs je me
tourne à nouveau vers laurence parent
puisque laurence on en parlait hier tu a
activement participé à la sortie d'une
résolution européenne sur le plan de la
relance culturelle de l'europe et
jean-jacques le disait fort justement la
culture céréalière par excellence entre
entre nous et je pense que laurence tu
partages complètement cette analyse est
donc tu as été avec un certain de
députés européens en pointe pour alerter
la commission européenne en disant
attention ne négligez pas le secteur
culturel parce que c'est aussi ça qui
nous permettra de maintenir les liens
entre nous est-ce que tu peux nous en
dire un an
oui bien sûr c'est le constat de ce que
rappelait jean jacques aillagon c'est à
dire que cette période de confinement
est là elle a permis une expression
culturelle et un dirait un partage très
généreux des artistes qui ont mis en
ligne gratuitement la musique les
oeuvres les des concerts chez eux etc et
qui ont finalement contribué à tenir le
moral des troupes dans ce moment très
difficile
et puis une réalité économique parce que
ils ont fait ça pour 0 par ailleurs leur
secteur et a été le premier à fermer et
on dit et dernière ouvrir ils sont
toujours dans cette difficulté dans le
même temps on a vu que toutes les
plateformes vod américaines ont fait des
chiffres absolument colossaux or ils
vivent avec la production des artistes
donc en effet le constat était très
simple on dit l'europe mais 750
milliards sur la table et bien en vue
que ses 750 milliards il soit aussi
fléchés vers des secteurs particuliers
qui ont fortement souffert qui sont clés
dans en effet dans cette notion
d'identité de lien et que qui
contribuent en plus de notre économie
que ce soit celle du tourisme en
particulier on est aujourd'hui dans les
journées européennes du patrimoine on
sait très bien qu'on vient le patrimoine
est clé pour pour faire vivre l'économie
des des plus petite dimension
territoriale
aujourd'hui il y aura plein de gens qui
vont visiter des châteaux des églises
dans les villages mais pour autant voilà
tout tout tout cet ensemble c'est ce qui
nous fait communauté et dans un grand
désarroi économique donc en effet cessé
merci de le souffle
le parlement européen a voté à une large
majorité une résolution une résolution
c'est un texte non contraignant mais
c'est une volonté politique pour dire il
faut sauver notre culture et lui assurer
là une rémunération juste voilà très
très rapidement le sens de cette action
merci beaucoup laurent c'est pour plus
d'information celles et ceux que ça
intéresse peuvent aller voir bien sûr
sur le site de la commission européenne
et du parlement européen alors je vais
me tourner maintenant vers silom labiche
parce que au modem on a la chance
d'avoir des élus locaux très impliquée
dans sur leur territoire et trade en
actifs pour porter nos valeurs sixième
tué chargée de la politique de la ville
de l'éducation populaire et à
l'agglomération de saint-etienne de la
cohésion sociale
on a évoqué avec nos quatre intervenants
incertain ou d'enjeu c'est important les
aidant les personnes âgées le lien entre
générations
l'accès à la culture pour tous est ce
que toi siham qui est impliqué dans une
grande ville à saint-etienne c'est 115
mille habitants s'épargnant est-ce que
tu peut éclairer nos téléspectateurs sur
la manière dont dans une ville comme
saint-etienne vous essayer d'unir les
générations de lutter contre l'isolément
des aînés mais mais mais les allemands
que généralement peu tous les
intervenants le raclette isole isolement
actuel à la fin alors comment on fait
pour lutter contre ça comment est ce
qu'on fait cohésion sociale en ces temps
difficiles
est ce que tu peux si l'âme nous donner
quelques exemples concrets de ce que
vous mettez en oeuvre à saint-etienne
alors s'il n'y avait pour l'instant tu
entends pas vas-y alors leçon va arriver
normand
patiemment alors on n'entend pas siham
alors on a
que que le som reviennent pour siams il
a réussi peut nous aider parce que
j'avais vraiment envie de la faire
intervenir si on tente en page je suis
désolé mais le ca va être résolu très
rapidement peut-être jean jacques
aillagon du coup un exemple de politique
intergénérationnelle en bretagne là tu
es élu et je repasse ensuite la parole à
siem d'abord jeu j'aimerais rebondi
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit laurent ce
robot justement du lien et de la prise
de responsabilité de l'union européenne
à l'égard de la culture prix de
responsabilité extrêmement progressive
n'est que j'espère plus accentuée au
cours des prochaines années
l'europe est par excellence un
territoire de culture à la fois partagé
et fractionné donc je crois que le but
des politiques eu lieu culturel et si on
veut contrer l'europe c'est justement de
faire en sorte qu'un des initiatives de
plus en plus nombreuses arte par exemple
en est une les européens aient le
sentiment de partager un patrimoine et
un avenir culturel commun leur sur la
possibilité pour la culture d'être un
ciment des liens intergénérationnels
justement la période récente
dans la mesure où elle a parfois limités
l'ambition des festivals locaux a
également incité ceux qui en sont les
animateurs à prendre des initiatives
extrêmement intéressante ici à poubelles
ou par exemple l'été se déroule un tout
petit festival extrêmement sympathique
qui s'appelle festival la pile
d'assiettes c'est le nom de la dépens de
rochers au large de plougasnou et cette
année le festival ne pouvons pas pour
des mesures sanitaires se tenir en un
seul lieu et y accueillir beaucoup de
monde ce festival c'est sur un véhicule
agricole déplacer dans les différentes
parties de la commune
et c'est notamment installé au foyer
logement dont klaus
trouve des personnes plus âgées que nous
parfois d'ailleurs de mon âge mais qui
ont été tout particulièrement atteintes
par l' isolement car car imposer le
confinement
j'étais pour ma part extrêmement ému
récemment impressionné par la capacité
de jeunes artistes de jeunes musiciens
de jeunes ne comédiens finalement de se
mettre de plain pied avec des
spectateurs inhabituels des spectateurs
beaucoup plus âgée que ça crée un moment
d'intensité de partage culturel créé à
la fois émouvants s'agissant des
sentiments qu'on peut éprouver et je
crois également extrêmement encourageant
pour l'avenir justement toutes les
initiatives de partage de la culture
nakouh beaucoup jacques pour fait
exemplaire
d'émouvants et très illustre très bien
le propos que nous développions à
l'instant alors on a retrouvé siham je
crois à siham si tu nous entends c'est à
toi pour d'autres exemples à
saint-etienne sinon tu n'as pas l'air de
tu nous entends si la main nous
n'entendons pas le siam
j'essaie de voir si la technique résout
le problème
bon alors on tente en baisse de 6 désolé
pour cette difficulté
merci à nice d'animer cette parenté
alors aujourd'hui on vit mieux on vit
plus longtemps il faut le dire et on
peut constater que l'allongement de
l'espérance de vie fait désormais
cohabiter plusieurs générations sauf que
certains la chance d'avoir une famille
sur qui compter il leur apportant radi
havre de plaît beaucoup d'amour et
d'autres malheureusement qui n'ont pas
ou qui n'ont plus cette chance d'avoir
une famille et qu'ils vivent au
quotidien une solitude qui peut parfois
leur être fatal et qui doit quand même
interpeller les acteurs publics qu'une
somme la puissance publique l'état et
les collectivités locales doivent
pallier cette carence quand celle ci
existe on doit assumer ses
responsabilités pour répondre à ces
situations d'isolement doit mettre en
place des politiques publiques avec pour
objectif je crois le bien-être social
la population et en tant qu'élu je crois
qu'on devons porter ce modèle de société
qui tend à favoriser les démarches
d'entr'aide les liens
intergénérationnels une vraie solidarité
de proximité à des actions concrètes
je crois que c'est l'une des voix qui
nous peut alors pas la seule l'une des
voix qui nous permettront de répondre
aux enjeux de cohésion sociale et donner
envie à l'ensemble de nos valeurs
républicaines et notamment celle de la
fraternité qui est si chère à notre
mouvement
alors au delà de la théorie à la
pratique il ya l'action et c'est ce que
nous devons encourager auprès de nos
élus en charge des problématiques
concernés mais aussi auprès surtout des
acteurs associatifs je crois qu'il faut
vraiment s'appuyer sur les acteurs
associatifs sur l'éducation populaire
mais aussi sur les enfants de
l'éducation nationale afin de faire
vivre des solutions au plus près des
habitants
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on fait à
saint-etienne depuis 2014 et que nous
allons amplifier parce que ça marche
alors saint-etienne c'est une ville de
soissons 174 mille habitants tu as dit
tout à l'heure à liszt 115000 14 mille
habitants avec 25% de la population qui
a plus de 60 ans et presque 23% de la
population qui a moins de 18 ans sachant
qu'on trouve en plus de nombreux
étudiants à saint-etienne et ces deux
tranches d'âge sont donc importantes et
le maire saint-etienne mangal perdriau a
très vite fait du bien grandir et du
bien vieillir des priorités absolues du
mandat ou chacun quel que soit son âge
devait trouver les moyens et les
possibilités de s'épanouir
alors concrètement pour faire vivre
cette cohésion sociale il faut inscrire
obligatoirement c'est incontournable
l'intergénérationnel au coeur de nos
différends politiques publiques en
poursuivant trois objectifs fondamentaux
alors d'une dialyse 1 je peux les
décliner tu peux nous donner peut-être
ici et je vais donner des exemples très
bien mais le premier objectif d'abord
pour nous et pour tous les élus que ce
soit aux autres c'est de lutter contre
la solitude contre l'isolément des
personnes âgées en mettant en place
différentes actions
alors je veux donner juste trois
exemples et puis je reviendrai s'il ya
des questions on a mis en place par
exemple à saint-etienne ne passe loisirs
seniors qui est un dispositif qui offre
douze entrées à des activités sportives
culturelles ou de loisirs un carnet qui
a une valeur de 200 euros et que nous
proposons à 10 euros pour les seniors
les plus précaires on a mis en place
également le réseau des bénévoles qui
une plate forme donc qui met en
connexion des jeunes avec des personnes
âgées qui ont besoin de passer du temps
avec d'autres on a mis aussi en place
des commissions bien vieillir tous les
mois qui met autour la table des
habitants des structures d'éducation
populaire des directeurs d'école où tous
les professionnels de la santé pour
réfléchir à comment mieux accompagner
les personnes qui sont isolés au sein de
leurs au sein de leur quartier
le second objectif pour nous pour chaque
élu lé c'est de garantir une connexion
entre les deux générations de créer des
temps de rencontre où les deux parties
vont apprendre à se connaître et donc
pour le coup à se respecter
les jeunes ne diront plus assez vieux
sont inutiles ou les aînés ne diront
plus assez
jeunes qui posent problème je crois que
c'est vraiment important je vais donner
trois exemples dans un quartier à
saint-etienne ni un signe dans ce
quartier pas d'antiquaires il ya aussi
des jeunes et bien les jeunes de ce
quartier qui n'avait jamais mis les
pieds dans ce cimetière dans le cadre
d'un chantier éducatif organisé par le
centre social voulons le jour de la
toussaint accueillir accompagner et
aider les personnes âgées à trouver une
place de stationnement à trouver la
tombe dans le cimetière parce que
parfois dans les grands sites hier on
s'y perd a déposé les fleurs sur la
tombe et a raccompagné à la sortie des
aînés ça c est un exemple concret qui ne
coûte absolument rien il ya d'autres
initiatives qui sont portés
essentiellement par les équipements les
acteurs de l'éducation populaire qu'en
tant qu'élu on doit soutenir très
fortement ce sont tous ces temps de
rencontre et de partage entre les
centres de loisirs les écoles et les
maisons de retraite qu'elle soit
autonomie ou qu'elle soit ehpad
ce sont des initiatives en plus qui vont
dans le sens des recommandations qui ont
été formulés par dominique libault dans
son rapport sur la loi du grand âge qui
a été remis au premier ministre et qui
assiste justement sur cette impérieuse
nécessité de ne pas penser le bien
vieillir uniquement sous l'angle de la
prise en charge du soin mais dominique
libault va soutenir va défendre avec
force que le lien social permet aux
personnes âgées
quel qu'il soit mais notamment pour les
plus dépendantes a retrouvé de la bonne
humeur et donc va venir impacter leur
santé le dernier exemple qui répond
peut-être à l'une des questions des
internautes et janvier selon son prénom
c'est la construction à saint-etienne à
valence et à montpellier et je crois
qu'il ya d'autres villes aussi qui vont
sur ce projet la construction d'un
village des aînés pour rompre avec la
forme des ehpad aujourd'hui c'est une
cité des aînés qui est ouverte sur le
quartier et qui propose des parcours
résidentiels des personnes qu'ils ont la
possibilité de vivre à domicile et
ensuite selon leur santé peuvent évoluer
dans un ehpad avec des services de
proximité restaurants loisirs le partage
des espaces pédagogiques avec des
enfants de la crèche et du centre de
loisirs et
terminerait je serai pas plus longue à
nice le dernier objectif c'est de chacun
la possibilité de participer activement
à la vie de la cité
en créant par exemple ou à saint-etienne
le conseil consultatif des enfants le
conseil consultatif des jeunes le
conseil consultatif des seniors osé
d'habitants divers et variés dont sont
nées de nombreux projets de nouvelles
réalisations qui sont visibles sur
l'espace public
je n'aurais juste un exemple c'est la
création d'un filet au parquet on avait
une place en plein milieu d'un quartier
qui était entouré de nombreux langages
logement d'une école de deux centres de
loisirs d'une maison de retraite et sur
cette place se dérouler les activités
que personne ne veut voir dans sa ville
pour faire secours trafic de drogue et
grâce à la réflexion qui a été porté par
le conseil consultatif des enfants et le
conseil consultatif des seniors on a
créé avec la participation du
gérontopôle de la région un physio pas
dans lequel les personnes âgées peuvent
pratiquer une activité sportive sur des
agrès réfléchi et construit par des
designers les enfants peuvent jouer sur
une aire de jeu installé par la mairie
et les familles peuvent se retrouver
dans des espaces conçus pour elles et
par ce projet collaboratif
on a répondu finalement à deux
problématiques celui de la tranquillité
publique ont stoppé les nuisances et
celui de se faire rencontrer finalement
plusieurs générations qu'il se
côtoyaient pas auparavant alors j'ai
d'autres exemples encore éloquent mais
je sais que je suis prise par le temps
juste pour dire que tout ça ça a un coût
mais il faut l'assumer ce sont des choix
politiques
et puis il ya des choses qui ne coûte
absolument rien et c'est une volonté
politique de la part des élus mais
surtout aussi des acteurs associatifs de
l'éducation populaire des enseignants
des écoles des maisons de retraite sur
lesquels il faut véritablement quand ça
puis merci cia nous pour tout cet
enthousiasme que tu ne te plait merci
beaucoup fiable parce que c'est des
exemples très concrets c'est des
exemples pour certains un effet qui ne
coûte rien et parfois
on en tant qu'élu local locaux parents
et je suis bien placé pour le savoir
c'est vrai que finalement il ya un
certain nombre de choses qui plus est
peu de chose et que et qui nécessite
juste un peu d'énergie de coordination
et donc merci pour tous ces exemples
inspirants signal
je citerai un autre exemple avant
d'arriver à la conclusion qu'un jeu va
rendre l'antenne on peut citer également
bien sur le plan anti solitude à pau qui
dans le même esprit que ce que tu cites
et siham a évidemment fait en sorte de
mettre en lien et en interaction est en
mouvement tous les acteurs de la ville
et du monde associatif etc pour lutter
contre la solitude c'est effectivement
un exemple éloquent lui aussi alors on
arrive au terme de ce débat j'envoie
rendre l'antenne car nous aurons ensuite
michel barnier qui répondra à nos
questions je voudrais remercier
infiniment nos cinq intervenants pour
leur d'éclairage et leurs participations
qui vous permet d'aborder de très
nombreux sujets et je remercie aussi
bien sûr encore une fois et avec plaisir
merci à toute l'équipe du siège est à la
régie technique qu'il a vraiment fait un
travail remarquable vincent engine
diaries virginie allan caron carole et
film
filomena solène marquant elisabeth
m'amène jean-guy tous les bénévoles qui
ont fait un super boulot merci à tous et
à très bientôt pour de nouveaux départs
mouvement démocrate
à bientôt